there's such a packed program for you
today that there's really no time to
waste for me telling you this is a great
show today we might record this one
today we might actually save this one
today because the show is so packed that
it would be a disservice given the huge
news I have to discuss with you to spend
time talking about the show in a sort of
meta sense and so I'm not going to do
that I'm not going to talk about the
show we're just going to do the show
okay and at the top we have to talk
about the collapsing polling numbers for
Democrats not only in the house we knew
the house was probably lost but also the
Senate and there are a couple of
different suspicions I have about why
this is happening let's reset
historically in general one party wins
the White House first midterm it goes
very poorly for that party Bill Clinton
won the White House in 1992
1994 historic defeat by Republicans in
which Newt Gingrich Republican comes to
power as Speaker of the House and
significantly moves the Republican party
uh away from Reagan and towards Trump in
a story that we've told many times
before an exception to this was in uh
2000 and 2002 George W bush Republican
winning in 2000 Republicans actually
doing okay in 2002 considered
extenuating circumstances lead up to the
Iraq War Post 9 11 Etc but generally
we would expect Democrats to do poorly
in November
that being said it looked as though
Democrats were clearly going to keep
control of the senate in fact there was
a close to 70 percent chance according
to the 538 forecast that that indeed
would happen that has changed the Senate
at this point is basically a coin flip
it's a coin flip with like a slightly
heavier head side so it's like 55-45
that in fact those are the exact numbers
right now if you look at the 538
forecast it is a 45 percent chance that
Republicans take the Senate 55 chance
that Democrats win and if you scroll
down the 538 forecast page which we are
linking to you see the change
you see how the forecast has changed and
you see that after peaking right above
70 odds for Democrats in mid-september
it has been a slow collapse and then a
rapid collapse all the way to what is
now basically a coin flip now if we look
at the house Democrats were never
favored to keep the house but it didn't
look this grim and unfortunately the
range now of outcomes is with
Republicans just barely taking the house
by one seat all the way to Republicans
holding a nearly 40-seat majority
Democrats now have a 19 chance of
holding the house and if you look at how
those numbers have changed over time
uh sorry here it is you also see that
there was a similar inflection point at
which point it became a sort of two to
one disadvantage for Democrats in late
September it is now down to a one in
five shot for Democrats adding on to the
not particularly good news a court has
temporarily blocked Joe Biden's student
loan forgiveness which was one of the uh
actions that Joe Biden
um took which was booing Democrats and
improving odds for November so what is
going on here there's basically two
major stories here that I would point to
number one it is absolutely the case
that when the Supreme Court overturned
Roe v Wade
given that Americans support Roe v Wade
by a greater margin than at any point in
the Roe v Wade era that there was anger
there was Anger from men there was Anger
from women there was there was anger
about that decision because it is after
all a right-wing activist Supreme Court
at this time and there was renewed
interest in voting and there was energy
behind listen if this is what these
Republicans are going to do we've got to
elect some Democrats
the timing of that energy seems to be
dissipating and when you now ask people
what are the most important issues they
say economy and they say inflation Etc
so the the analogy I used over the
weekend on a live stream was if you are
getting ready for you know a big test at
school and you say I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna have a quadruple Express
espresso Express I almost said the thing
Express no I'm gonna have a quadruple
espresso uh and I'm gonna be all fired
up and ready to go and you take the
espresso too early and your energy Peaks
an hour before the test and then by the
time the test starts the espresso is
wearing off you've mistimed The Surge of
energy
and that is the analogy to what I think
happened here with Roe v Wade now the
timing wasn't up to us the Supreme Court
had its timing and I believe that that
is one fact uh one factor the other side
is that Democratic messaging has not
been very good and later we're going to
look at a clip from Gavin Newsom who
says the most dangerous states by by
crime rates are all red States and yet
we've let Republicans take over the
narrative and say violent Democrat
States violent Democrat States that's
just one example but I do think the
messaging from Democrats has continued
to be terrible and the messaging from
Republicans has continued to be
effective so those are two major factors
it's really not looking good do we give
up of course not I mean listen if you
live in Pennsylvania you get to vote for
the Senate you get to vote for the
governor and other local races
you might as well do it and then we see
what happens but the numbers overall
from a 30 000 foot standpoint
are looking increasingly bad for
Democrats and that is very bad for the
country because of the delusional
extreme nature of the modern Republican
party and by the way they're also
starting to intimidate voters let's talk
about that next this is an unbelievable
story you know the right loves to talk
about uh ballot drop boxes they're bad
they're not secure they're unreliable
and yet the reason that they are not as
trusted by some Americans is because
Republicans are saying you can't trust
them it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
it's a vicious circle it's endless and
now
individuals believe to be right-wingers
have been spotted in some cases armed at
Arizona ballot drop boxes Arizona
Secretary of State Katie Hobbs received
the report this week about an alleged
incident of voter intimidation video was
obtained by The Washington Post and
we're going to play the video here for
you and I will describe what is visible
there is a man who parks at one of these
ballot drop boxes and he walks over and
he dumps in his ballot perfectly legal
that's what it's there for this was on
October 17th this is an early voting
Dropbox and what you see is that after
he walks away
something gets his attention right
across the street he's apparently
engaging with someone right across the
street and it seems to start to become
sort of uh combative and the man later
reported that he was being watched he
was being photographed and he was being
heckled as he used that ballot Dropbox
and again if you're listening I'm
describing what's on video the
individual eventually getting into his
car uh backing up and ultimately driving
away but what he says happened was that
people were harassing him for using that
Dropbox and he ultimately decided to
seems like back all the way out
um and go in a different direction that
is exhibit number one we then learned
about on Friday two armed individuals
dressed in tactical gear showed up at a
Mesa Arizona ballot drop box we have
pictures here eventually the Maricopa
County Sheriff's Office arrived and the
individuals left uh there are folks here
you see wearing I don't even know the
terms for this stuff they've got like a
uh I can't tell if that is a leg a ban a
leg holster of some kind with one
individual they seem to have a tactical
vest possibly a camera uh who knows what
it is that that they all have but
reportedly armed individuals in tactical
gear again allegedly uh there to
apparently there
um to uh harass and intimidate and all
of the things that you would imagine uh
they would be doing and then there is an
additional report of people just hanging
out outside Maricopa County elections
headquarters in Arizona outside one of
two ballot drop boxes they have their
own cameras rolling they are filming the
dropboxes and uh here are people and
they they're all playing koi I can't
really tell you what I'm doing here
check this out
so what we're seeing right now is just a
bunch of cameras pointing at the
dropboxes
what was the name of the group you're
with again
clean elections USA
clean elections USA
you've been out here how long
I can't answer that
they claim that they have not said
anything to people dropping off ballots
they just have cameras pointed at the
drop boxes they have you know a dog a
bunch of cameras food
etc
etc now individually
is it against the law to just have a
camera across you know the parking lot
from a Dropbox I don't know I don't know
and that's what's being explored right
now but the totality of what's going on
in Arizona and I don't care who's doing
it if you came to me with tears in your
eyes and said sir these are all
Democrats I would say it's still wrong
okay I don't care who's doing it this is
all a form of voter intimidation and
there's also a story here of what
appears to be essentially inaction by
law enforcement
um which is another part of this that
we're exploring and may have more
information about uh about uh for you
tomorrow they are you know it's uh the
other day Marco Marco Rubio said listen
people don't trust these ballot
dropboxes right but they don't trust
them because you told them they
shouldn't be trusted it's completely
circular in every way and now in order
to set to be able to justify their own
claims that these drop boxes are just
trouble
they are creating trouble at the drop
boxes these are horrible people this is
not pro-democracy Behavior by any means
and we have to see to it that it is
stopped in Arizona
this is listen I don't know that I
needed to do this but we have now a
beautiful
significant statistically significant
double-blind
placebo-controlled trial of that little
old drug the anti-parasitic drug called
ivermectin for covet now I know it's
been a while and so some people maybe
say David where where is why did you
just pull this out of your ear no four
months and months and months
the indifferent to the science right
wing
was aggressively promoting something
called Ivermectin to treat covet they
would promote it prophylactically they
would promote it as an acute treatment
for covid there were people like the
candidate for Arizona governor Kerry
Lake who claimed she was just taking it
prophylactically to prevent covid and my
position was
listen test everything
test spinach
test niacin test diver Mech test
whatever but let's have double-blind
placebo-controlled randomized controlled
trials so we can accurately say these
things do work for covet or they don't
it would be great if we found something
cheap and widely available like apples
or Ivermectin that was good for covid
but unless we know that it works it's
irresponsible to claim that it does and
the right winger said you're suppressing
this and you're blocking that and you
don't want they they don't want the
truth to be known and the more and more
and more data that came out the more we
believed it didn't really work we now
have a very good study and indeed the
sugar pills worked better now I want to
be clear the headline is kind of a joke
right the headline is Ivermectin worse
than sugar pills the sugar pills are a
placebo and what you have is almost
identical effects between people
actually getting Ivermectin and people
getting the sugar pill so the headline's
kind of a joke but the truth is the
Ivermectin doesn't work study released
three days ago effects of ivermectin
versus placebo on time to sustain
recovery in outpatients with mild to
moderate covid-19 a randomized clinical
trial okay the key elements here the
question they were asking folks this is
a science right this is what this is how
we figure things out question does
Ivermectin daily for three days
compared with Placebo shorten symptom
duration among adult patients over 30
years of age in the United States with
symptomatic mild to moderate covet 19.
that's the question now you can always
come in and say they didn't dose it
correctly they should have tested five
days they should have tested it only on
severe covid or only on mild or
impatience of 25 years okay every test
is only testing something that's this is
what this test is uh thought trying to
figure out and the findings determined
that Ivermectin should not be used in
outpatients with mild to moderate covid
because it didn't do anything
okay when you look at design setting and
participants this is this is how we
folks this is how we figure out stuff
um this was a decentralized
double-blind
randomized placebo-controlled trial
okay decentralized means it wasn't all
done at one location it wasn't okay
we're doing a test at this one Hospital
everybody who's part of the test has to
be right here no it wasn't done that way
it was double-blind meaning neither the
patience nor the treating individuals
the medical professionals knew who gets
the sugar pills and who gets the
Ivermectin it was randomized meaning
that there was not a selection of okay
let's see u3 go in this group and then
u4 go in the placebo group because that
can then uh be affected by the bias of
the experimenters who might consciously
or subconsciously say let's let's like
put the healthier people in the
Ivermectin group because they're more
likely to do well no it was it was
randomized and placebo-controlled
meaning some people got
fake drug but they didn't know okay it
was designed to evaluate repurposed
therapies meaning drugs that already
exist but are being explored for
treating covid in outpatients with mild
to moderate covet okay
1591 patients 30 plus with covid with at
least two symptoms and an acute
infection less than seven days old
meaning they were started on the trial
before seven days of covet had gone by
okay very good uh participants were
randomized to get Ivermectin or a
placebo
the um okay results these are this is
the the most important stuff here okay
the most important things the median
time to recovery was 12 days for the
Ivermectin group and 13 days for the
placebo group now you might say well
look the Ivermectin group recovered one
day quicker uh that difference of 12
versus 13 days is not significant enough
to prove Ivermectin is more effective
than doing nothing the difference in the
number of people being helped by
Ivermectin and the placebo is so small
that there is not evidence that these
that one day difference is anything
other than just chance
um it's essentially the same and in fact
it's really a range the median time to
recovery was 11 to 13 days for the
Ivermectin group and 12 to 14 in the
placebo placebo group now importantly
what about more serious outcomes well
there were 10 hospitalizations or deaths
in the Ivermectin group and nine in the
placebo group
there were fewer deaths in the placebo
group and fewer hospitalizations and
deaths
um again not statistically significant
so the joke is the fewer people died
with the sugar pills the it's not a
statistically significant difference now
let's say what would be significant in a
group of sixteen hundred people with
covet right imagine that only 10 of the
people getting Ivermectin ended up in
the hospital but 200 of the people
getting the placebo ended up in the
hospital then we would say whoa that
seems very unlikely to be by Chance the
Ivermectin maybe was doing something
so the uh very clean very very good
study now some of you might be saying
why did we get that early data that
Ivermectin maybe worked for covid the
best explanation we have for that right
now
is that Ivermectin is an anti-parasitic
drug
some of the early populations at whom
they threw Ivermectin were in countries
with a higher prevalence of parasitic
infections in humans the Ivermectin
treated the parasites and overall people
do better
generally speaking when they don't have
parasites so
that would be the explanation of why the
Ivermectin may have shown a false signal
at being effective for covid um in some
very small early tests all right we have
the data we can put it to bed except
Carey Lake still talks about how great
Ivermectin is quick break right back
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
lest anyone forget I want to remind you
that the David Pacman show is a program
that depends on the support of our
audience to do what we do we've grown
over the years thanks to audience
support now with the multiple YouTube
channels and the multi-platform show the
live streams the podcast the YouTube
channel all of it uh you can sign up and
support the work that we do it's not a
lot of money but it really goes a long
way at
joinpakman.com join pacman.com you can
also use the coupon code Obama Obama to
get a discount off of the coast of cost
of your membership that is o b a m n a m
n is Mike Nancy
o-b-a-m-n-a and you'll get a tidy little
discount and instant access to the world
famous bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad very much so I appreciate
everybody who signed up over the weekend
listen uh I continue to have this very
significant significant interest in
Gavin Newsom as a possible 2024
Contender if indeed Joe Biden were to
not run for re-election Gavin Newsom is
not the Uber Progressive candidate that
maybe I would dream of but you go to war
with the Army you have not the Army you
wish you had and Gavin Newsom is doing
something very very important he is
accurately concisely and forcefully
describing some of the obvious lies that
Republicans are telling and that voters
are falling for and I have to tell you
he's using critical language about
Democrats but it is sort of tough love
and Democrats are terrible on messaging
on so many issues this issue of crime in
Democrat states and cities is just a
disaster last week I told you all that
in the Oklahoma
gubernatorial debate
it was correctly mentioned by candidate
Hofmeister that the rate of violent
crime in Oklahoma and Oklahoma City is
higher than the rate of violent crime in
New York state and New York City
respectively and that is absolutely the
case on MSNBC Gavin Newsom interviewed
by a seemingly smitten Alex Wagner who
was just enthralled with what he was
saying as she should be because he is
accurate when he talks about this stuff
saying why aren't we doing better on
this the numbers are on our side it's
not just a messaging Pub but a messaging
problem that has persisted with our
party for years and years constantly on
the defense we allow these cultural Wars
to take shape and we consist in there on
the back end of them eight of the top 10
states with the highest murder rates all
are Republican states yes how did
Democrats not know that in fact it's
really nine out of 10 Georgia went for
Biden but it's really a Republican state
at least a red State eight out of ten
and we're losing that message crime is
high higher as well as taxes here for
the average citizen in Texas it's higher
crime higher violent crime and poverty
crimes than in the state of California
67 percent higher gun death rate in
Texas why don't we push back I don't
know the answer to that why don't we
push back and remember in my story last
week we looked at some of this data and
one of the things that you see as I
mentioned is that you've got Washington
D.C with a very high violent crime rate
um in 2019 uh and then and also we have
the numbers now for 2020. but you
basically have red States it's Alaska
where violent crime is high New Mexico
is a blue State Tennessee Red State
Arkansas Red State Arizona went Biden
but basically a red State Louisiana
Missouri South Carolina South Dakota
you've got to get down to Michigan
before you get an actual uh another
bluest date and then it's Montana Nevada
Oklahoma Alabama Texas and then you get
to California and then you're almost
halfway done with the list you're almost
at 25. okay it's similar to the repeated
claims that Republicans are good for the
economy they these are just lies folk
we're going to lower the taxes and then
uh it'll encourage investment and then
just everything's going to be great and
the stock market will do well and
unemployment will be low folks go to the
numbers the the numbers aren't Secret
if you have access to Google you can
find the primary source numbers
overall
the economy does better by the following
metrics under Democrats
unemployment rate is lower
job creation is higher
inflation is lower
GDP growth is higher
stock market returns are higher there's
many others okay now if you want to make
a case that even though the numbers are
better when Democrats are in the White
House it's actually thanks to
Republicans because of either a lag time
which has been debunked or because of
who controls the house mattering more
it's also been debunked or right you
could but you've gotta start with the
data and that's what the data is I like
what Gavin Newsom is doing I like what
Gavin Newsom is saying hey this is just
beyond parity absent father Herschel
Walker
said in August of 2020 or no I'm sorry
in August
August 20th of this year
said that you can't have absent fathers
it's bad when people are absent fathers
he sort of ran on I'm going to make sure
we don't have absent fathers but he's an
absent father it's absolutely
unbelievable this is an interview
between Herschel Walker and diamond and
silk
and to be totally honest now I'm not
sure was this in August of 2020 or
August 20th of 2022 doesn't matter okay
absent father Herschel Walker has a
message about absent fatherhood
and let's become fathers of those
fatherless child ah meaning let's try to
direct them in the right way yeah yeah
what can I just say this here okay so
you don't raise your child now you got
to go and try to be a father to somebody
else what about teaching our black men
that if you lay down with a woman and
you make a baby it is your
responsibility to stay there to make
sure that that child is raised well
that's what I'm talking about give them
good values that you have that you say
you know what and I said this is someone
else if you have a child with a womb
even if you have to leave that woman
even if you have to leave that woman you
don't leave the child right right you
let that child know you try to work it
out you're going to be respectful to her
if you're going to be respectable to
other things you show that to your child
yeah now unfortunately not following his
own advice number one Herschel Walker
completely absent as a father
to it look I
how many kids this guy has at least
absent to some I believe two kids
it's very hard to keep track of and also
recently denounced by his son Christian
Walker you'll remember that multi-t
multi-teat multi-tweet screed which
included quote I know my mom and I would
really appreciate it if my father
Herschel Walker stopped lying and making
a mockery of us you're not a family man
when you left us to bang a bunch of
women threatened to kill us and had us
move over six times in six months
running from your violence
couldn't he just tell the truth about
anything anything oh uh absent fathers
are bad well he's an absent father I'm a
police officer no he's not I trained
with the FBI I'm authorized this way and
that way no you didn't I ran some what
was the business he claimed he ran and
he did it's hard to even keep track of
the lives and the Republican voters
don't care because they either assume
that it's fake news that he's lying it
can't possibly be
or they straight up say listen Rafael
warnock's a Democrat I'm not voting for
him uh and of course however could I
forget abortion is murder no exceptions
ever and then he goes and pays for a
woman's abortion after urging her to get
it and then urges her to get a second
abortion which she declines to do
horrifying we will have this clip on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
the big political rally of the weekend
was when a soaking dripping wet Trump
showed up to very windy Texas supposedly
to campaign in favor of Texas governor
Greg Abbott and Texas lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick and Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton it was all about
himself it was all about me me me I'm
the victim everything bad happens to me
and yeah I guess vote for these people
sort of if you need to or if you want to
uh a very scary rally Trump not only
looked disoriented glitched about a
dozen or 14 times most rallies he brain
glitches two or three times but glitched
at least a dozen times but also saying
things that are so crazy that we have to
wonder if Trump really believes this
stuff something must be going on where
he has entered an alternate reality one
that doesn't exist here He suggests he's
going to sue to get people's Pulitzer
prizes taken away and then wants Fox
hosts to be given Pulitzer prizes
fantasy world he might as well be on
Nars so you have reporters from The
Washington Post the New York Times
they've got bullet surprises
the exact wrong thing so within the next
two weeks we're suing the Pulitzer
organization to have those prizes taken
back that's almost certainly not going
to happen and of course if it does no
prizes are being taken back
foreign
[Music]
think of it they got the Pulitzer Prize
for Roan reporting
but other people
should have gotten the Pulitzer Prize
because frankly they got it right for
years
and they don't do like surprises for
guys like Sean Hannity oh but they
should by a different name and Tucker
Carlson and Janine Pirro imagine giving
Janine Pirro a Pulitzer Prize that that
but uh you know most belligerent
monologue
and Laura and so many different people
but they don't get anything they give
police
uh really really scary wacky stuff and
then of course Trump pulled out the c
word no no not about women guys you get
your mind out of the gutter I'm talking
about the word communism for our very
eyes Biden and his left-wing handlers
are turning America into a police state
and I don't even think it's fighting to
be honest with you but they got some bad
people around Now understand that at the
same speech he said Biden and Democrats
don't care about our police they're
defunding police they're getting rid of
police and turning America into a police
state with which police
like something straight out of a
communist country see I used to say
socialists but we've skipped socialism
we don't talk about that I don't even
mention it anymore we're not socialists
anymore we're Communists we've gone over
socialism we're gone it's over it's
Communists they're talking about
Communists it's a communist system now
of course there is absolutely nothing
communistic about Joe Biden whatsoever
uh in fact he's he's almost too much of
a Centrist for the social Democrats to
even like him but all of these terms
meaning less essentially because Trump
and the people behind him don't even
know what they mean Trump then continues
to tell the lie that it was Nancy Pelosi
who failed to use the military on
January 6th he's the commander-in-chief
of the military though we talk about the
fact that Nancy Pelosi refused to use
the military and they didn't need 10 000
to 20 000 if they had 500 people it
would have been more than enough now of
course Donald Trump was the
commander-in-chief of the military at
that time and remember Trump claims he
ordered 10 000 troops and Nancy Pelosi
said no there is no evidence that Nancy
Pelosi said no to anybody not nor that
she has the authority to and there's
also no evidence that Donald Trump
ordered 10 000 troops you know like you
order a Big Mac uh simply no evidence of
that at all at another point during the
rally Trump alluded to a really insane
conspiracy theory that there were
satellites that changed votes from him
to Biden so we've heard about there were
massive dumps we've heard about you know
the number of sandwiches didn't make
sense that they brought for the poll
workers we've heard all these other
conspiracy theories but this is a this
is an extra crazy one this paper about
it's the old-fashioned way that's the
way you're going to stop would you agree
with that Mike that's the way you're
going to stop it
it's the only way
we don't need satellites sending the
signals all over the place somebody
votes let's see I'm going to vote for
Trump I love Trump I'm going to vote for
Trump trump being because all over the
world comes back by how did that happen
yeah also it's kind of crazy that if you
see you know some of these conspiracy
you sometimes come across conspiracy
theories that are not based in reality
but they have an internal logic where
like if you accept that the conspiracy
is possible and exists it has an
internal logic this one doesn't even
make sense you're going to in instead of
just flipping the vote on the machine
you're going to send the vote through a
series of geostationary satellites and
then it'll come back as a vote for
someone else like it's overtly it's
overly complicated it doesn't even make
any sense
um Trump then this was maybe the most
depraved moment of the entire thing
Trump said the way to get the
information out of the Russia dossier
uh person
is to put them in court and tell put him
in jail and tell them they'll be raped
in jail and the crowd laughs at prison
rape easily made public you know in this
country they leak all over the place
even on the Supreme Court by the way you
have to find the liquor of the supreme
but you have to find them
you know how you find the leaker they'll
say oh this is treasonous what I said so
they can't find the leaker he leaked all
about row v Wade look this person leaked
from the Supreme Court never happened
you know how you find but they don't
want to mention this because they think
it's so terrible you take the writer
because you're never going to find
another going through phone records it's
been a long time you take the writer and
or the publisher of the paper a certain
paper that you know and you say who is
the leaker National Security
and they say we're not going to tell you
they said it's okay you're going to jail
and when this person realizes that he is
going to be
the Bride of another prisoner very
shortly
[Applause]
he will say I'd very much like to uh
tell you exactly who that leaker it was
built so the joke is our prisons are so
unsafe sometimes people are sexually
assaulted oh that Donald Trump is so
clever uh dystopian moment the a group
of Q Anon type people interrupted Trump
and started singing the National Anthem
at the rally and Trump allowed the
entire thing to go on time he talks she
cries dogs these are the people we have
but remember this January 6 this
committee the two things they didn't
talk about two things was that the
people went down there and you could
have had over a million people
cult
[Applause]
so understand and they sing the entire
thing understand what happened there
okay cult leader Trump
was bemoaning that they are going after
the January 6th rioters and as he does
that in a show of defiance and seemingly
support for the rioters and I guess
they're implying the rioters did
something very patriotic the crowd
stands up led by a sort of conspiracy
group in the front row area based on
reports I've read and start singing the
National Anthem this is a cult anything
the cult leader says must be defended
and if it says if he says something
really crazy you get up and you sing the
national anthem Trump then ranting about
the boxes continuing to make wild claims
this time about presidents putting boxes
in Chinese laundries and I can assure
you this does nothing to exculpate Trump
from what he did with those documents
and look at to me for a long time Dr
Ronnie I'll tell you what they found
nothing they have found
one thing I will say they found that I
like you am a great Patriot
it's a disgrace what's going on
like the boxes hoax have you looked at
the boxes hoax okay this is a new one
the boxes you know Mar-A-Lago have you
seen the last five or six presidents
what they did they took it they're in
Chinese laundries they're stored they're
in storage houses where the windows and
doors are broken it's a disgrace
now we've already looked at each of
those claims individually they're all
either deceptive or outright false but
it doesn't matter they they just grow
while the Q Anon music played then Trump
attacked electric vehicles we are a
nation whose leaders are demanding all
electric cars
even demanding though they can't go far
cost too much and whose batteries are
produced in China with materials only
available in China
an unlimited amount of gasoline is
available inexpensively in the United
States but not available in China yeah
um there are now this is conservatively
two electric vehicles with a 400 plus
mile range there are
um 15 electric vehicles with a 300 plus
mile range and there are uh almost 20
with a 250 mile range so it's it it it's
it's just pathetic now maybe the
cultiest moment of the rally Trump calls
up Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton to
speak when you go up there if the cult
leader gives you an opportunity to speak
you should damn well better know
that you're supposed to just praise the
cult leader when you're allowed to speak
and that's exactly what Ken Paxton does
hey
so Mr President Dan Patrick and I were
over here asking how does this President
draw a crowd year after year thousands
of people unlike anybody we've ever seen
and and so I've been sitting here trying
to figure it out right
and and the the question I thought was
what did you determine Ken Maybe
it's this man no clearly is a great
businessman but I don't think that's why
everybody's here maybe it's because
you're a great golfer I don't think
that's why everybody's here
this President and the people that come
to see him are here because in my
opinion you tell me I'm right he's done
more for the American people than any
president in our lifetime
[Music]
so he was certainly on message he knew
exactly what he was supposed to do scary
cult rally these are serious cultists
serious interventions would be necessary
to get them out and if you need more
proof of that let's look at some of the
interviews with the cult members so
you've got your cult leader which is
Trump and then you've got your cult
members who are the trumpists who go to
the rallies there was a rally in Texas
over the weekend we already looked at
clips of Donald Trump speaking check out
some of these interviews one of the
funniest things to me is when someone
repeats some conspiracy theory and they
don't even really understand it and it's
sort of like whatever whatever the
conspiracy theory is I believe it and
here's a guy who says listen they stole
it was either one million or a hundred
million votes in Texas and of course
Texas doesn't have a population of 100
million how could you steal 100 million
votes doesn't really matter check this
out below
could turn blue she said that two years
ago so if they cheat which Lindell said
there was a hundred million or a million
vote stolens yeah there were there was a
hundred million or a million votes
stolen in Texas now one of those numbers
is of course mathematically impossible
but it doesn't matter to these people
they just you know I I hate to do this I
really do because I sometimes I think
adopting the language of the right
doesn't make sense but they talk about
they love to say that there's leftists
who are NPCs non-player characters these
are just like the background characters
in video games who just they just repeat
stuff they don't do anything they repeat
do the same motion and over and over
again that's what these people I don't
know Lindell said it was like 100
million votes were stolen in Texas maybe
one million I don't know but clearly it
happened here's a woman who raises mules
yes who raises mules and she drove 17
hours to the rally opened the people's
eyes to the corruption in this
government he did more than any
president in the history of this country
by the way she raises mules I love the
hat it's my 30th rally
17 hours
got here Wednesday I'm from east
Tennessee understand another
uh characteristic another trait of Cults
and cult members
who is willing to go the farthest
literally and furthest figuratively
to please and show Devotion to the cult
leader
here's a guy at the rally explaining
that the biblical principles that Trump
adheres to are why he loves Trump the
biblical principles that Trump Embraces
is what really uh what I really like
about him I've never heard another
president invoke the name of God and
Jesus more than I've heard president
Donald Trump J Trump and that's the the
main thing for me is that he's embracing
biblical principles and follow the Bible
and you can't go wrong yeah
um now it is true that Trump will invoke
the Bible frequently of course he does
it only as the most obvious form of of
uh pandering and we say who could
possibly fall for that well that guy
fell for it that guy fell for it uh the
leader of Latinos for Trump I don't even
know if that's real she says God sent
her to the rally to deliver a very
important message to Donald Trump are
all of these people merely mentally ill
no I don't think so I think it's it's
radicalized politics in some cases
combined with mental illness and by the
way couldn't God deliver the message to
Trump himself why didn't he did he need
this lady a message for Trump I I have a
message from the Lord for him and I'm
I'm need to get that message to him to
tell tell him that he is to call this
nation to fast pray and repent including
himself and all the leaders even Faith
leaders because God wants his people
back and he wants Trump back and Trump
used to surround himself with faith
leaders and then covet hit and he was
separated from Faith leaders right that
was the real tragedy of covet Trump was
separated from all of the pastors and
you know um he thinks he's fighting
in a bigger realm that he maybe doesn't
understand or no one's explained it to
him and I don't know if he's surrounded
around people that just won't let us get
this message to him but it's important
for that I've been traveling the United
States identifying those leaders that
can be assembled that understand yeah
well she's going to give us that list
and we'll examine how many of those
people should be in prison
um a guy at the rally said that he was
in Washington DC on January 6th he knows
exactly what antifa looks like and it
was definitely antifa what did you see
that there
I saw lots of antifa and I know how to
recognized them in the crowd I was out
on the west coast I was like a big
Burning Man festival person so I've seen
these antifa scum I know what they look
like I smelled a rat I didn't get
anywhere close to the Capitol because I
was gonna wait and see uh what it was
gonna be like let's also not forget her
everyone forgets where zamboiling if I
ever have a daughter I'm gonna name her
Roseanne after Roseanne Boyland and of
course Roseanne Barr the other greatest
American I'm sorry Roseanne Barr
Roseanne Bar all right okay yeah it's
all getting kind of a little bit weird
um one guy was asked what's the thing
you love the most about Trump here's his
answer what is the one thing you loved
about President Trump
um
just not caring about what other people
think and getting respect from other
countries now
yeah the truth is respect for the U.S
was at a historic low under Trump and
these folks just they refuse to
acknowledge that or they don't care
um and then here is a January 6
defendant trennis Evans who was one of
the people in Nancy Pelosi's office he
says he coordinated with the Trump team
to do the national anthem hearing that
you LED this effort with Donald Trump
tonight to sing the Star-Spangled Banner
talk about it yeah we have been pushing
uh actually we came up with this idea on
Wednesday and I started pushing kind of
late in the game here asking can we
restarted through social media pushes we
reached into the president's Camp
everywhere we could I'm a j6 defendant
myself so I reached into the camp
everywhere we could just saying in
solidarity yeah he's a j6 defendant and
of course we need to show our solidarity
with the rioters why I don't know but we
need to these are these are obviously
delusional people
but these are dangerous people and it
should not be and listen I hate to do
something so crass but remember with the
Manson cult
um they were not just followers
they were activated to become murderers
and the cultists can be just as or more
dangerous than the leader
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right a couple other quick stories
that I will not spend a ton of time on
right now many of you wrote to me and
said David uh Trump advisor Stephen
Bannon has been sentenced he got four
months in jail and that is true but he's
not going to serve a day of it at least
not for now because of an immediate
appeal so the update on that you might
recall that Trump advisor Steve Bannon
was subpoenaed by the January 6
committee he ignored the subpoena he was
um charged with contempt of congress he
was found guilty he has now been
sentenced indeed as the Associated Press
reports Bannon was sentenced to four
months for defying the January 6th
subpoena uh District Carl District Judge
Carl Nichols however allows Bannon to
stay free pending appeal a potentially
lengthy process and also imposed a fine
of sixty five hundred dollars as part of
the sentence pretty strict huh 6 500
bucks Bannon was convicted in July on
two counts of contempt of congress one
for refusing to sit for a deposition the
other for refusing to provide documents
uh Nichols handed down the sentence
after saying the law is clear contempt
of congress is subject to a mandatory
minimum of a month Behind Bars bannon's
lawyers said you could give him
probation prosecutors said give him six
months and my view said the judge Mr
Bannon has not taken responsibility for
his actions you think others must be
deterred from committing similar crimes
prosecutors argued Bannon deserves the
longer sentence because he pursued a bad
faith strategy
and his public statements disparaging
the committee itself made it clear that
his goal was to undermine their effort
to figure out what happened on January
6th he chose to hide behind fabricated
claims of executive privilege and advice
of counsel to thumb his known at his
thumb is nose at Congress your honor the
defendant is not above the law and that
is exactly what makes this case
important it must be made clear to the
public to the citizens that no one is
above the law
um so sentenced if he ultimately serves
the four months because now there will
be a very lengthy appeals process and
who knows if he will
is four months even a serious deterrent
and what I mean by that is
hard of defying these subpoenas to the 1
6 committee
is about showing loyalty to the cult
leader showing loyalty to the cult to
Trump I'm going to stay true
I'm going to ignore the subpoena
if four months is all that is at the
worst case waiting for you on the other
end of it it doesn't seem like a
particularly strong deterrent from
continuing to show your loyalty to the
cult now again I have to mention this
because of the comments I'm seeing about
oh bannon's going to get raped in prison
he'll learn real quick first of all
the place Bannon is likely to go would
be like a lower Security Federal
facility the type of place that Michael
Cohen went to
there's not a lot of prison rape
happening there but more importantly
I've said this before and I want to say
it again
when people talk about oh you know even
if they only get four months it's going
to be worse because they're going to get
raped in prison
that is a disaster the fact that our
prison system is so ineffective at
keeping prisoners safe that sometimes
their sexual assault shouldn't be
something that we relish and say well
you can count on the punishment being a
little worse guys it's disgusting okay
and I don't care if the sentenced
individual is a Democrat or Republican a
progressive a conservative or whatever
the fact that sometimes people are
sexually assaulted in prison is just a
reminder of how a poorly functioning our
prison system is so let's not stoop to
that level Bannon is appealing let's see
what if anything he ultimately serves
hey this is really funny um it this is
not the the biggest news story but Ted
Cruz went to Yankee Stadium a place I've
spent many many hours at and uh he was
at Yankee Stadium because the Houston
Astros Texas baseball team are playing
against the New York Yankees and
everything about it is just completely
humiliating at one point Crews cheering
for the wrong team but the funniest part
is actually something that has
dramatically improved my opinion of
Yankees fans I've been to many you you
know I grew up in Massachusetts I'm a
Red Sox fan but I've gone to many many
games uh at Yankee Stadium when the Red
Sox come to town
and I you know never cause any trouble
or anything like that but trouble
sometimes Finds Its way to Yankee
Stadium uh during big rivalries and I
have to tell you that I just love love
love the Yankee fans here here they are
noticing that Ted Cruz is coming in
listen to the treatment he gets
racist
place
yeah so really getting the full
treatment there from the Yankee fans
also another really funny moment
um in this in this clip you're going to
see
the Yankees pitcher strikes out the
Houston batter and you see Ted Cruz
wearing a bright orange shirt and a vest
right behind home plate he cheers at the
guy he's supposed to be rooting for
striking out Cruz doesn't know what's
going on uh uh I'm gonna play this
actually without audio you can see here
in comes the pitch and then it's in
there for a called third strike and Ted
Cruz cheers
[Laughter]
oh dear God he is just the worst and
then here is another little quick video
of Ted Cruz leaving and again getting
getting the full treatment
alone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go back to Cancun now more substantly
substantively in terms of New York City
Ted Cruz voted against hurricane Aid uh
after Hurricane Sandy ravaged New York
and New Jersey back in 2012 and then in
2017 after Hurricane Harvey crushed
Houston he was saying give us money give
us money give us money and when you ask
him aren't you a hypocrite he was like
oh no no Sandy was all pork none of the
money went to the victims which of
course was not true he's horrible truly
horrible we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P here's a very
good question listen to this
hey David why do you think that personal
finance at least very basic concepts
aren't taught in the public school
system in the U.S I'm not sure if other
countries do teach it but just something
as basic as intro to finance something
something simple why isn't that part of
public school system and the curriculum
yeah listen that's a great question
everybody would be so much better off
if personal finance started to be taught
certainly by age 12 if not younger
saving just basic you could start very
early
there's a few different reasons number
one there's the claim that public
schools just can't afford it you know
they say listen we've had to get rid of
woodworking we've had to get rid of a
bunch of sports stuff a bunch of
electives we just don't have the money
for a personal finance class is it true
or not well you know it's all about what
you prioritize but that's one reason
that there aren't such classes uh
another reason is Teachers lack
financial literacy as well they weren't
taught it either so finding teachers to
teach the class is sometimes a challenge
parents are often not fluent in Money
Matters and they may not even know to
request it as something that should or
could be taught maybe there's a bit of a
taboo around money that's a factor as
well but it would be a great idea to
start teaching personal finance early
I think part of a sign of the demand for
this and the need is how quickly our
finance channel has grown the the Pacman
Finance Channel which we launched about
a month ago youtube.com pacmanfinance it
already has 12 000 subscribers none of
our channels none of our platforms have
ever gotten their first 12 000
subscribers this quickly and I think
it's clearly because there is a need
there is a desire for personal finance
info so find the channel youtube.com
pacmanfinance we've got a great bonus
show for you today producer Pat will
join me you sign up at joinpakman.com
you will get instant access to that book
thank you